[Music]
oh you want to get ice cream yeah I'm
going to get you ice
cream huh
yeah yeah oh there it is you want this
one I'll get you french
[Music]
fries
I'm so sorry about this
pal
really I'm going to need a credit
card here's my membership card I think
you'll see I've got a few rewards points
there it's not really how it works it's
like a oh you know maybe with all those
points I don't even need a credit
card what do you think leevon are we
good how many points do we have looks
like you are Platinum Elite Superior
Diamond members and I would love to help
all right stop collaborate and list is
with a new advent a of me TI like
and I don't know turn off the light
andow the
ex
stage speak that BS I'm killing your
brain like a poisonous mushroom dead
when I play a dope Melody anything the
best is a it believe it you better
gain kid don't how good
is Che the
DJ
[Applause]
Baby Hold
On oh hey
b hey Dan have a good one all
right
[Music]
passports are out of
date from here on in Daddy's paying in
cash
maxi we're going to Las Vegas today well
you said you wanted to be more
spontaneous I heard you and Jorge said I
could take a few days off is Jorge the
one that do hyro massages on Tuesdays no
Mrs Kesler Jorge is Dan's boss is Dan
giving me a hydro massage no Mrs Kesler
there's no massages today the kids have
a long weekend and they're pumped right
guys guys tell your mom how pumped you
are for this
trip woo oh so pumped Dan we can't just
up and go to Vegas I mean and why Vegas
I know it's not Europe but there's a
Venice and and a night Tower you know
what I bet you wouldn't get last minute
Adele tickets You Love Adele You Love
Adele of course I Love Adele who doesn't
Love Adele I Love Adele everybody loves
the D she's got the voice of a freaking
angel come on Jess what is holding us
back who are you I don't even recognize
you oh you're going to love him he's
crazy and Dad oh o are you sure it's not
Tuesday whoa what are you doing
up oh you want me to do the thing
huh wait wait
go be
wipy new
record we have to leave because my
former coworkers are trying to kill us
from planet car deals I'm not kidding
around ask Max before I met your mom I
was a covert assassin I escaped at life
and now they found
us dad you are like the biggest swim on
the
planet thank you move go
now oh hey Dan happy
anniversary Dan my husband he's an
amazing dad you almost ready to go to
size four rest huh how you so big look
at the big musos I just wish our lives
were
bigger really at least let me put my kid
down up on a six sorry about the mess
hold
on oh hey b hey
Dan don't hang up I need no identities
I'm burned me my wife and three kids
have you told them yet I'll tell them
when I'm on the road meet me in Vegas in
3 days this is crazy God we're going to
Vegas woo oh so pumped nothing brings
the family together like a road
trip stop collaborate and listen is back
with a brand new adven something TI 5
hours on a plane or 33 hours in a car
can someone unlock the car
please call in
everybody I want him
F what was that little pothole Maxi's
been up the whole time by the
way wish
that before I met your mom I was a
covert assassin I escaped that life and
now they found
us what
the being your husband and their father
that's the real
me you're like James Bond in a minivan I
love that
minivan I need to be that guy one last
time for
usaby look at you playing the family man
I'm not playing this is my life
hey I'm kind of into spontaneous
dance wait
[Music]
wait new
record when I first heard that he was a
part of this project I knew I had to be
a part just to share the screen with
him he's up there you think there's I
mean there's way he does like all his
own stunts and then and then Wham he's
on set doing this like insanely
intricate fight scene he's already
accomplished so
much car jumps skydives motorcycle
chases eating solid foods
even did you eat all the chocolate you
did didn't you Max Max Max Max you can't
help but be in awe of him you're about
to go to size 4S huh are you so big now
huh look at the big musos you find
yourself wondering what's he going to do
next next crushing the
peas he's so sweet he's great he's a
teddy bear he's become basically my best
friends he's the real Action Hero around
here
[Music]
really we need to get out of the city
before I met your mom I was a cobt
assassin I escaped at life and now they
found us dad you are like the biggest
whm on the
planet what in our new movie The Family
Plan we play a family on a perfectly
normal road trip we're going to Vegas
woo oh so fun nothing brings the family
together like a road trip that's why
we're here with some road trip tips to
make the miles go by even faster all and
everybody about them
F Lead Foot a squirrel or something
jumped out in front of me uhoh first
load up on
snacks really remember to stretch out
and get a little
exercise oh my God watch out for road
hazards and you should make it there in
one
piece mostly 1 2
[Applause]
[Music]
he